On average, men die about seven years earlier than women,...
...and male lions, rodents, and spiders often go belly up...
...before their female counterparts too.
One big reason males live shorter lives than females...
...might be hidden away in the chromosomes that help determine sex in the first place.
Welcome to MinuteEarth.
In lots of species, males are more aggressive and take more risks,...
...so you might expect they'd die first...
...and in many species like humans, they do.
But males aren't always more aggressive,...
...and the more aggressive sex doesn't always die first.
Instead, when you look across the animal kingdom,...
...the animals that die earlier, regardless of their sex,...
...have something else in common:...
...they have a small sex chromosome.
Sex chromosomes generally come in two sizes: big and small.
Part of what determines the sex of an individual...
...is the combination of sizes they inherit.
In mammals like humans, females inherit two big sex chromosomes,...
...while males inherit one big and one small.
But in birds, butterflies, and some reptiles and amphibians,...
...the opposite is true:...
...males get two bigs, while females get a big and a small.
In most cases, the sex with the small chromosome tends to die first...
...regardless of whether they are the males or females.